if we're to have any hope of eliminating
greenhouse gas emissions then we will
need what they make in this plant just
outside Swindon for this is where
Johnson Matthey makes the chemicals and
membranes you need for green hydrogen a
fuel produced without carbon emissions
the UK doesn't make many batteries or
solar panels but this is one area where
we're genuinely competitive but the boss
here says that's no longer a given well
I think the risk is
um over time we will lose another
leading cutting-edge industry where the
UK could be a global Champion so I think
batteries is gone we we've lost that we
don't move with that sense of urgency we
will lose that next
um a round of innovation as well that's
real jobs for the future
um future-proof jobs for the next
decades so I think this could have a big
impact it's like many other firms is
looking at subsidies being thrown at
Green Technology firms in America by the
White House's inflation reduction act
and asking what about the UK the lack of
of certain being priority is a problem
today and practically again a lot of
jobs are getting created in the U.S
right now those some of those jobs could
be created in the UK but because of lack
of clarity and certainty they're not
getting taken now
um so it's already it's already costing
potential jobs for sure for sure many in
business are now wondering whether this
might in hindsight turn out to be the
moment the UK dropped out of the race to
build the green technologies of the
future this is one of those rare areas
where the UK is actually a world leader
when it comes to the chemicals that are
pasted on what are going to be kind of
membranes going inside fuel cells in the
future the issue is so much of this
technology so much green technology has
been drawn away to America where all the
subsidies are and the UK is now faced
with an awkward question what's it going
to do to try and encourage businesses
like this to invest here here in future
so what to do about it the problem is
even if it wanted to Britain can't
compete with the hundreds of billions of
dollars being thrown around elsewhere we
need to really choose where the money
can make a difference because otherwise
you either subsidize something that was
happening anyway or you subsidize
something where we're not very good at
it and we then find ourselves pouring
more and more money into it so we need
to be yeah it's hard work it's not a
casual business
the green Industrial Revolution is fast
turning into a race but for the time
being it's not clear whether the UK is
competing and how much help its firms
will get to do so